most stars like the sun formed 5 billion
years before the sun now we didn't hear
the cries for help from those
civilizations that were on these
habitable planets like the Earth and
said wow we're losing our oceans we're
losing everything they cried for help
they must have sent lots of spacecraft
in fact most of the interstellar objects
most of the interstellar crafts may have
been launched at this last phase when
the civilizations that were highly
evolved technologically realized we're
about to die a lobe joining us uh all
the way from the Eastern Seaborn cdge
Massachusetts Harvard and we have a new
friend joining us today also young and
distinguished and that's uh Professor
Gary Nolan so we've got three professors
here in this pre-thanksgiving
uh day that uh it's my favorite holiday
and I couldn't be more grateful than to
share it with uh such a wonderful uh set
of guests thank you guys for joining me
Gary how are you today up north great
thank you and up north yes yes up in The
Frigid North of Paulo
Alto and AI is jealous of that frigidity
I'm sure AI how are you sir I'm doing
great but most of the universe is much
colder than the earth so I I feel
sympathy to the rest of the universe oh
that is great well uh for those of you
who are new to this channel we have
conversations with the greatest
luminaries in science technology
engineering and math we have uh
luminaries ranging from 14 Nobel Prize
winners uh four billionaires and that
includes Ai and Gary uh so those are two
new billionaires uh we've had guests on
from all over the spectrum of culture
and today we're having a very special
pre-thanksgiving episode which is to
discuss and and have a a gentleman's
debate about the impact the import the
knowledge and the future of unexplained
aerial phenomena and this is an area
that these two gentlemen have made a
contribution I want to thank you guys in
particular because uh you know a lot of
what we do when we are expressing an
interest in this uh in this subject gets
met with derision with um maybe attempts
to humiliate to dis to discredit folks
that are interested I find that uh
repugnant but uh but the fact is you
guys are some of the most distinguished
intellects on this planet we're very
lucky to to have you in this community
but you're also incredibly open-minded
so I don't expect you to reply to that
uh but I just want I do have a reply I
just wanted to um mention that in
politics you see it very often that
there is polarization where you have the
extremes on both ends uh fueling each
other because one side says nonsense and
then the other side uses it as fuel to
say also nonsense and then you end up
with a situation that doesn't make much
sense and uh the middle ground of Common
Sense is not
populated H not in politics these days
and I would say not in Academia and uh
also on this question of unidentified
objects because what I realized is first
of all you know as an astronomer I was
driven into it by data that implied an
object that looks really unusual and
that what happened to be the first
object from outside the solar system
that we identified called the mua mua
and since then we find two others before
it meteors with my student we can talk
about it yeah but the point is these
looked unusual they didn't look familiar
so I said okay let's stud them and of
course the subject was ridiculed by
mainstream astronomers and then they
tried to explain those things in terms
of rocks that we had never seen before
objects that we had never so to me I
mean it it didn't sound like they are
trying to use familiar objects to
explain them but they appealed to
unfamiliar objects that still keep them
sort of relaxed that they are natural
and so forth so they dismissed any
possible association with other
technological civilizations even though
we ourselves launched five probes to
Interstellar space and you know why not
imagine that others did it as well
billions of years before us and then on
the other hand you have those believers
who would interpret anything unusual in
the sky in terms of being
extraterrestrial and the reason I say
that is you know when Ukrainian
astronomers reported about some dark
objects and didn't have good distance
estimates for those and I suggested that
maybe got the distance wrong and as a
result these would be just artillery
shells uh those Believers jumped at me
and said you know it must be EXO teres
because there could be new physics and I
say well for new physics you really need
a very high bar you know like we work
really hard we you need Exquisite data
to convince you that you are missing
something in the known physics and you
can't just jump into a conclusion about
new physics because you know you see
something that you didn't really measure
well okay okay if it's sloppy data that
cannot be justification for new physics
you need to have Exquisite data to argue
for so you see this polarization of two
sides and one uses the other to justify
their extreme positions so the
scientists say we don't want to be to
share the same bed with those people
that don't believe in the scientific
method and those that don't you know
those Believers on the other hand say
look at the scientists they don't pay
attention to this so my point is
populating the middle ground that makes
common sense and following the
scientific method is
unpopular okay and that is really
surprising to me I thought it's only the
realm of politics but over the past year
I learned that it's the realm of science
as well in some areas yeah and we've
we've talked uh before about new physics
uh but today we're going to talk about
new biology and that's courtesy of our
of our new guest on the show which is uh
which is a real treat Gary Nolan uh
you're perhaps you know along with AI my
most frequently requested guest on this
subject and I just want to introduce you
to my my audience you know most of the
Nobel laurates I've had on are
physicists although I have had on a
Stanford Professor weedo imbens who's a
colleague on campus and I have Jay
bataria not a Nobel Prize winner yet but
he's coming on next um to talk about his
experiences with a Galileo like Affair
that we'll talk about when he's on uh
but Gary's an immunologist an academic
an inventor business executive uh helps
to uh to to lead or or or works with six
different companies he holds the
Ratchford and caroleta a Harris
professor in dowed chair and the
department of pathology at Stanford
University School of Medicine uh usually
Gary and AI knows this I usually ask you
to start off by describing your latest
book but you told me uh you prefer
papers and uh and I wna I just get a
quick tease of this upcoming paper if
you're allowed to to talk about it just
from to set the stage in your Bona fees
for my physics minded audience
oh we've got well and let let me first
riff off of something that uh AI was
just saying about this you know this
divide and you know I think a lot of it
begins with something that I've always
focused on especially in my lab meetings
is finding the point which is off the
the line and paying attention to it and
not ignoring it because you can continue
to walk that line and continue to
basically do conventional science but
it's when you see the point off the line
and you try to explain it either as
being an error or as something that is
indicative of either you know new
biology or new physics or new
observations Etc you know I and I think
I'm mean I've been having this
conversation with a fair number of
people lately about you know what is a
standard of proof and you know the
standard of proof really differs
depending upon who you are you know
science has a standard of proof that
says you know I I can reproduce it I can
hand it the data to you you know I it's
not an anecdote I mean I have my own
anecdotes of things that I've observed
that you know in standard science might
be thought of as preliminary data it's
preliminary data it's sufficient for me
to get sufficiently interested but it is
not something that I could hand to
somebody else and say here is proof of a
new object or a new physics or what so I
think we we I think one of the things
that is important for both I think what
AI is doing what I'm doing is to teach
the lay public what these different
kinds of proof structures are that
enable one to be thought of as say a
Believer or to be thought of as a
scientist now a Believer isn't a
negative thing I mean religions are
believers but they if you want to take
the realm of religion and belief and
hand it over to science that's where
this disparity
happens so I'm I'm happy to occupy that
middle ground where AI is basically
arguing we should be a scientists and
argue to the people on my let's say far
science extreme and say you know what
you guys are acting more like priests
than you are like
scientists uh so why don't you come a
little bit closer to this line and then
you say to the people on the far other
side you're acting more like you know
you're not act you're acting more like
priest and if you want to talk to the
scientist you need to come to the middle
and so let's find a way to to create
languages which allow the two sides to
talk to each other that said I'm not you
know this is not the UN I'm completely
willing to ignore both sides just do the
work create the data publish a paper get
it peer reviewed and say there it is now
you try to argue with the data that I've
just presented you and if you can't come
up with a different conclusion that
justifies the data and at least the
speculations I'm coming up with then get
out of here yeah Brian if I may just add
yeah go ahead Abby two two short points
one there is a a Common Thread between
spirituality and the frontiers of
Science in both cases you are exploring
the unknown and we should be humble in
the sense of not assuming we know the
answer in advance you know a lot of
scientists
H do their job in order to demonstrate
that they're smart it's all about
themselves you know they will do
mathematical gymnastics even if the real
Universe didn't show that there there
are more than three spatial Dimensions
they will just show that they are smart
for 50 years by doing manipulations in
extra Dimensions even though we have no
clue for that now I say okay five years
10 years reasonable 50 years is starting
to be excessive and the point is it's
not about us not demos you know showing
off it's about learning about nature and
unless unless you get some dialogue with
nature getting some evidence for what
you're doing you're doing math
mathematics okay and you are trying to
show off but you're not explaining
nature so that's a first thing first
thing is we need humility H to learn
from Nature by experiments to get the
feedback and respect the data whatever
it is if it looks unusual we should not
brag that we know everything in advance
that we are experts that we can explain
everything by past knowledge we should
be open-minded to new knowledge the
second Point uh that you know that is
really important is that science is
about the signal to noise ratio yes okay
what does it mean there are all the time
noisy you know fluctuations things that
happen by chance that do not signify
anything unusual it's just rare
phenomena that happen now and then okay
and what people fail to understand like
in a war zone if you go to Ukraine you
increase the level of Noise Okay that's
why I was reluctant to consider Ukraine
because there is a there are lots of
things flying in the sky many of which
we don't know because the US government
wants it to be classified or the
Europeans want it to be classified or
the Russians want it to be but there are
things flying in the sky all the time
this in increases the level of noise in
the sense that we don't know what they
are okay and there would be spy
satellites all kinds of things you have
to realize that given that the noise
level is high the chance of you sign
seeing something that you don't
understand is higher okay so it's all
about how significant is the signal that
you detect relative to things that
happen by chance in the environment that
you're looking at and that's something
that the public fails to uh follow
because they say we will go to the war
zone because maybe they will be there
but then you have to understand that
that burden of proof is actually higher
it's higher if you are in a noisy
environment you have to work harder to
demonstrate that there is something
unusual going on and you know that very
well from the cosmic microwave
background from studies of the UN I mean
we looked for fluctuations in the cosmic
microwave background Relic from The Big
Bang for many decades until the signal
to noise ratio per pixel was above one
at that point it was detected and before
that it was not so it's really all about
the not just the signal but how unusual
is the signal relative to some random
occurrences in the environment that
you're looking at yeah I think that's uh
that's often missed out and and one of
the things that I most frequently hear
about is that uh there's you know kind
of a conflation of the of the notion
that these are legitimate phenomena to
study but also that they could be
representative of much more plausible I
mean effectively much more plausible uh
explanations they could be um you know
hallucinations or mass delusions they
could be military s Ops there could so
do you guys think that a lot of the kind
of um dereliction or the or or the
denigration of this subject Gary I'm I'm
interested particular to get to to get
your take on it because you've been
incredibly courageous and uh it's almost
like when you talk about it you're
immediately assume that you must cleave
to one camp or the other so I want to
ask you in in keeping with Avi said do
you did you come into this field I mean
this is not your field you're an eminent
world renowned scientist uh did you come
into this fill with any preconceived
notions that there were phenomena and
then so so there's been a great
sacrifice that you and AI to sux then
have have undertaken so explain what was
your motivation how did you what's your
origin story in this Gary well I mean I
mean I have two Origin stories if you
will I mean and I I've been open about
this I mean I saw an object when I was
young as a as a paper boy uh and it went
right over my head it was you know it
was un uh un mistakable uh you know that
it was not supposed to be there but I
was what I think I was 11 or 12 years
old I don't really remember um but I
didn't know what it was but I remembered
it years later so that when the whole
subject of what UFOs or whatnot might be
I could look back on that and say well
you know in so far as what everybody
else is claiming this to be that was a
UFO it was clearly it to me it looked
like technology it had lights uh it was
making no noise it was 30 feet over my
head uh and it was you know 5:30ish in
the morning um but you know as I I
explained this to to um Avi at one point
uh it's an anecdote and so it is it is
not sufficient for me to use that as
proof of anything except to myself to me
it it currently motivates me to continue
to look into this because some level I
want to prove not only to myself that I
wasn't seeing something uh but I want to
prove to others that it's it's worth it
but I got you know I I got brought into
it uh by basically a visit by government
agencies and an aerospace Corporation
asking me to help them understand how uh
pilots and uh intelligence Personnel or
how they had been harmed and they you
know they came to me because um my lab
had developed or involved in developing
uh one of the world's most advanced
blood analysis uh uh instruments and
they said okay well in the in part of a
a larger medical workup on these
individuals is would you please help us
look at the blood of these individuals
to look for signs of inflammatory
disorders uh and they showed me data uh
and that data was sufficient for me to
get more and more interested in this and
then I got you know shown additional and
more data and frankly it was just like I
was saying before it was data off the
line and that didn't just it I'm just
drawn to that kind of stuff I mean it it
is one of those kinds of unsolvable
problems that are just was begging for
an answer and I suppose the reason why I
continue to get more involved is because
people told me not to get involved other
scien oh you shouldn't be doing this
it'll ruin your career and I just it
just I had an an inner Welling I guess
of anger about it is why would you even
say that you're it seems that you're
closing your mind to some fascinating
possibilities and anyway it's my time so
why do you care right right I think
that's the you know kind of the the the
you know to whatever extent there is a
conspiracy and I'm not a conspiracy
minded person I don't think you guys are
either but there is a um a desire not to
think about these things I mean I me Avi
mentioned religion earlier um you know
one of the reasons there's a conspiracy
there's a conspiracy by scientists to
tell you to not think about it which
isn't like it's being driven by anybody
behind the scenes right it's like this
it's like this uh I don't know it's like
they're afraid of being painted with a
brush of your belief even though I'm not
asking them to believe in it but what do
you say to somebody Avi who says look
you guys are I mean they're gonna bring
out this card you guys are three chaired
white male professors you are the peak
of privilege blah blah blah um how can
you legitimately say AI that you there's
a conspiracy against you you're one of
the most Peak performers the planet has
ever know I mean how do you answer those
kind of critiques well there is no
conspiracy I don't believe in those but
I wanted to mention that two-thirds of
the America of all Americans believe
that there is extraterrestrial life um
and that's more than the number you know
the the nearly 50% that believe God
exists okay so and then there was a poll
recently uh by Elizabeth stanway in the
UK she pulled of all 350 astronomers and
94% of them admitted that they uh were
fascinated with science fiction and and
then um 60 something perc of them AR
suggested that they chose astronomy as a
result of reading science fiction and um
you know thinking about them
extraterrestrial intelligence so I say
to myself well it must you know resonate
very deeply with those astronomers and
with the general public the only
question is why professionally they put
this makeup of pretending they don't
care about it they don't want to fund it
and they want to assume that the
universe as a
zero uh assumption that the universe is
dead lifeless which is pretty much what
cosmologists do all the time and um you
know I I do believe that unidentified
aerial phenomena are a mixed bag I think
many of them are probably used for
Espionage but by other nations uh I
think that some of them are just weather
balloons or um you know drones or US
Government developing some equipment
that others are not aware of or you know
it could be
some you know natural phenomena like
birds or or thunderstorms or whatever or
meteors but it's sufficient to have one
object which originated from an
extraterrestrial origin for this to
change the future of humanity because
imagine us finding a gadget and you know
the chance that the gadget was produced
by a civilization which is exactly at
the same technological phase as we are
is minute because we developed our
Science and Technology over one century
quantum mechanics was discovered a 100
years ago and all of our gadgets are
based on that understanding of quantum
mechanics just 100 years my my point is
that's one part in 100 million of the
age of the universe so most like and
most stars formed five billion years
before the Sun so most likely they're
much more advanced than we are whoever
produced this gadget and we can learn a
lot it um you know and and one thing we
need not to worry about that's something
that Stephen Hawking argue that you know
we should be really careful they might
harm us I don't think so I think there
so much Superior to us it's just like a
biker you know driving down the sidewalk
and what the colony of ants does in the
crack of the pavement is completely
irrelevant I mean they can decide about
a protocol how to engage with a biker
but that doesn't really matter so I
think we are dealing with something far
beyond us which in a way you know is a
similar to religions that believe in in
something much more powerful so I I
that's why I said that spirituality and
the frontier of science may have
something in common well let me you know
since you've heard my Spiel a little bit
ofy but maybe Gary hasn't um you know I
of the three of us might be you know I
mean I think we're all skeptical I think
that's the job of a scientist to be
skeptical but also approach things with
an open mind and maybe the latter is not
as common as the former should be and
the default reaction of a scientist you
know should be essentially as Isaac
azimoff said you know that's odd not
like Eureka I have found it um but I've
said to you OB I've said you know the
first of all the the the appeal to
popularity right so I was in Europe
recently at Galileo's house I mean this
is amazing I was at Galileo's prison
house in Florence in aret and uh and I
was there and I was thinking you know at
the prison bars on there that he was
imprisoned for saying something
essentially that was that was true and
that didn't go against the prevailing
religious doctrine of the day in other
words uh the the person who came up with
the idea that the Earth was the center
of the universe wasn't you know Jesus
Christ it was Aristotle and té now you
guys know better than than than the
average person those were pagans right
so why did the Catholic Church Avi did
you know this that the Catholic Church
uh you know made Aristotle effectively
baptized him 1,400 years after his so
that the so that the sun could not be
the center of the universe I I well no I
mean you can understand it from a
political point of view because if
people uh if you flatter the EOS of
people they adapt your Doctrine so in
order to attract more Believers what you
would argue is that we are Central to
the universe we are Central actors God
is really focused on us and then people
will believe you if you say oh we are
just side actors you know there are much
more important things happening in the
universe and we are just we happen to be
here by chance and then people say well
you are just depressing you know like
this Doctrine is not appealing to me I
want to be at the like all the alpha
males want to be at the center and guess
what if you were to tell Putin that by
conquering a piece of land he would look
like an ant hugging a single grain of
sand on the landscape of a huge beach
you know he would be really upset but
that's the truth you know the universe
is huge we are insignificant we just
came at the end if you come at the end
to a play and you are not at the center
of the stage guess what the play is not
about you but people don't like that
message they want to be Central and
important they want God to look over
their shoulder and re respond to
everything they do and as a result if
the church adapts this doctrine that we
are Central to the universe they get
more Believers so I think it was serving
a very good political purpose basically
well that that brings me to a to a
question for Gary so that that uh one of
my friends uh um here in San Diego
wanted me to ask you why should we
expect along the lines of what ABI said
the centrality this notion our Cosmic
ego and significance why would we expect
or should we expect that alien would
even have DNA or or have any kind of
chemical composition like we are is that
something that we would abono expect in
in other words is DNA the fundamental
operating system of life in the universe
uh or would we are we being too um what
do you say anthropocentric by assuming
that if there are life forms that they
must be quote unquote like us well I
think you can you can take that question
in two directions I mean one there's
plenty of evidence that uh the raw
materials for DNA are everywhere um
that's pretty clear um there's some
there's two interesting papers that I'm
aware of about uh about sort of the the
panspermia um notion uh one of them is
it's sort of applying Moore's law to DNA
uh regulatory complexity and the the the
regulatory programs that uh you can
infer uh from everything from you know
viruses through bacteria yeast up until
us and the the premise is that you can
essentially show that there is a Moors
law of genetic
complexity that uh would uh you can draw
across the timeline of um life on Earth
the problem with the timeline and the
mors complexity is that it goes It goes
back to and points to a a time about 8
billion years ago when life lik
uh exist or started in terms of if it
were a linear line now you so there's
two solutions to that it either happened
8 billion years ago well before our uh
solar system was around and got here on
meteorites or uh other uh basically
modalities or it rapidly ascended in the
complexity basically happened in maybe a
100 million years and then uh achieved
linearity um so that's that's one
fascinating uh aspect and it's it's a an
interesting published paper people can
go and argue about the math if they want
I'm not going to get into the that arle
you know the authors of that Gary so I
can put it in the text um I'll I'll go
find it for you I haven't got it on on
my computer here but um no problem I'll
put in later it's a Moors law um
argument about it it's fascinating and
the other is the so-called it's called
the wow signal in the in the genetic
code um and it was by a couple of uh
scientists from I think it was aeran
mathematicians looking at the at the the
genetic code structure and essentially
laying out again a mathematical argument
that the DNA code the genetic code for
determining a triplet of bases into into
proteins was
designed right and so they said that
basically that's the wow signal that
we're all looking for now again I mean
the problem I mean it's a fascinating
argument and the math looks good uh but
um the problem is it falls pre to the uh
to
the the attack that you you you can't
apply simple linear mathematical
approaches to Evolution it's the same
thing that you know the uh the selfish
Gene of Richard Dawkins his beautiful
book um basically lays out that you know
just because the eye didn't
Abino uh evolve out of nothing it
doesn't mean that there's a God involved
but the wow signal it's a it's a
beautiful it really is a beautiful paper
it's a think piece I posted it in the in
um it's overlaid your face right now but
I see it there no no it's great um and
you know I just again I I don't think
it's proof of anything Kazakhstan not
aeran I apologize to both Nations don't
start any wars in that part of the world
please Gary yeah but I think that those
are those are two papers that
um
underpin the sort of scientific notion
that this panspermia effect can be at
least analyzed by traditional approaches
mathematics at the least but then the
other is you know I think you go back
and and probably AI knows this as even
better the so-called notion of bolman
brains right are you aware of this Brian
the bolman brain yes we spoke with Sean
Carol about that and uh yeah I mean it's
it's fascinating that you know you you
can perhaps have organized plasma or
organized objects in 3D space that if
they could be uh if they could
self-contain themselves there's no
reason that they cannot be conscious
right it's not life as we understand it
but you could still imagine it as
conscious or Consciousness and you know
if if such existed it's been around
since the beginning of of what we would
call time that's right yeah if I may add
Brian um what traditionally humans
called God in religious texts in
philosophical texts you know there is a
lot of philosophy around it could
simply be attributed to an advanced
scientific civilization because we are
getting to the point where we will uh
develop life in our Laboratories and you
can and again it's a 100 years after
modern science started so you can
imagine that a civilization that had a
million years of scientific work might
know how to unify quantum mechanics and
gravity even though for 5050 years
string theorists were not really able to
come up with predictions maybe a more
advanced civilization was able to figure
out how to unify quantum mechanics and
and and gravity and and engineer that
knowledge okay so once you understand it
you can engineer it and create perhaps a
baby Universe in the laboratory and so
my point is that here is a
path it's often thought that religion
and science are somewhat contradictory
but that's if you stick to traditional
Notions but it could well be that you
know when you advance to a high enough
level of intelligence you realize that
what we called God is actually a
manifestation of of a much higher level
of intelligence or scientific
development and that's where I think
that we can bring philosophy religion
and science together it's not
necessarily contradictory let's just but
for that we need to be
open-minded H we need to allow H when we
attend the class of intelligent
civilizations allow for a smarter
student in the class not just say we are
the smartest there is nobody else in the
in the room but rather say let's check
okay because that was the biggest shock
my daughters had when I brought brought
them on the first day to kindergarten
they realized there is a smarter kid
around you know like that is a shock and
a lot of people prefer not to look and
say we are the only ones in class and we
are so smart that nobody else exists out
there and I say well you know you be
behave just like those people who put
Galileo in house arrest because they
didn't want to learn about something new
let's let's go back to the pans spermia
by by the way this I I can't resist that
uh on my channel I like to give away
stuff and one of the things I give away
are meteorites H here are some
meteorites uh and uh Gary brought it up
of course and and I can't resist so you
can actually win your own meteorite if
you go to my mailing Les Brian king.com
list and you'll be entered to win a
drawing of a real genuine meteorite that
crashed into Argentina about 5,000 years
ago was discovered in the 1500s and was
used for tools and and other sorts of
implements and and it's really fun and
I'll send that to you I may even send
one lucky winner some uh Uranus soap
because you need to keep Uranus clean as
we all know uh but but uh but actually
my point is a serious one so panspermia
works both ways right so I want to ask
both of you guys um maybe starting with
Gary Pence Premia should work the
opposite way in other words life on
Earth should have disseminated
throughout the uh throughout our solar
system and over the billions of years
you are absolutely right uh the origin
of life you know better than me uh we
believe started about four billion years
ago in other words it's just a few
hundred million years after this
meteorite uh was created in the same
Proto solar system right the fact is we
don't observe any evidence for life in
our solar system I'm not saying it's dis
positive as I think Carl San said uh you
know lack of evidence is not evidence of
lack uh and you know there's my favorite
finger puppet of of Carl Sean I've got
all sorts of props I'm a prop Cosmic
prop Cosmic uh but I want to ask you
Gary to what extent can we use in aasian
framework the lack of observation of any
trace of any existence of life on a
meteorite on uh on another planet as
some constraint on the facund argument
that life should be ubiquitous once it
gets started so I don't think that the
basian framework operates here in two
for two reasons one we haven't done the
real test first of all I mean so we sent
uh I mean actually the department that I
got my PhD in here at Stanford the
genetics department um they actually
built the experiments uh that were done
on Mars and the Viking
Landers uh and you know there was
there's actually been a lot of post talk
analysis of that original data that said
that this actually probably was evidence
of life but um strangely and I don't
understand this I'm not saying that it's
a conspiracy or anything they they keep
sending back microscopes that look at
rocks but they don't send back a growth
Media or anything to try to see if
something if they were to drop a piece
some dirt from Martian soil in it if if
any Critters grow bacteria or what have
you so you know so first of all the
experiment has been done so you can't
populate the priors in the and inference
uh there um second well Venus at least
from the you know Viewpoint of um the
kind of life that we would be looking
for is is not a not a nice place to be
if you're if you're life but you know I
mean I think we're all looking at the at
the Under Ice oceans around the larger
planets here and I would I I would bet
any amount of money that we're going to
find something under there I mean all
the necessary requirements for the kind
of life that we think of are going to be
there um water heat uh and probably
things like hydrogen sulfide or or other
Redux related chemicals that would be
sufficient for growing uh let's say the
even primitive life will will be there I
I 100% sure that that's where it is
going to be here is an interesting
anecdote let me just mention that um you
know if there was a news media back two
and a half billion years ago they would
say some good news and some bad news
about life in the solar
system because what happened was that
Mars lost its atmosphere around that
time and it used to have liquid water on
the surface it's pretty obvious based on
all the data we have from uh the
perseverance Rover more most recently so
there was clearly there were clearly
lakes and eventually for some mysterious
reason Mars lost its atmosph I mean it
it it has a much lower gravity than the
earth but there was some event that
caused it to lose its atmosphere and as
a result all liquid water on its surface
all all life form so we might find
evidence that life existed on early Mars
because it was not very different from
Earth early Earth now around the same
time two and a half billion years that's
a complete it could be a complete
coincidence or maybe not but the oxygen
level in the ATM atmosphere of Earth
Rose abruptly we don't know why I mean
we know what produced the the oxygen
canano bacteria but we don't know why
there was this sudden rise in the oxygen
level and that of course enabled all the
chemistry that allowed complex life
forms like ourselves to exist okay
without that we wouldn't exist there
wasn't much oxygen in the first half of
the life of the earth and both both
events occurred at the same time there
was bad news on Mars good news on Earth
for intelligent life or complex life and
maybe they were related I don't know but
when we look at other planets one thing
to keep in mind is you know that we have
a 50% chance to conclude the the to
conclude that life exists if there is
oxygen because there was microbial life
on Earth for half of its life without
much oxygen in the atmosphere and the
second is that within a billion years
from now the sun will boil off all the
oceans on on Earth okay so even Earth
will lose its atmosphere and the water
on its surface and that's 1 billion
years from now so that's like 20% left
you know we don't have much time left
anyway and all the tricks we are doing
about global climate change and so forth
you know it wouldn't change much when
the sun will heat up the surface of the
Earth right good thing we have tenure
though now most stars like you say we
have 10 years that what you say that's
right but one thing to keep in mind most
stars like the sun form five billion
years before the Sun so they already
went through that now we didn't hear the
cries for help from those civilizations
that were on these habitable planets
like the Earth and said wow we're losing
our you know Atmos we're losing our
oceans we're losing everything and we
and they cried for help there must have
been sort of a a an immediate Exodus
they must have sent lots of spacecraft
in fact most of the interstellar objects
most of the interstellar uh crafts may
have been launched at this last phase
when the civilizations that were highly
evolved technologically realized we're
about to die okay so they sent
everything as much as they can and so
most of the things we find in the inter
Med may be relics from that desperation
but we couldn't hear them because we
were not around and you know these radio
signals passed by the earth when
microbes were around we were not there
to hear them and we will go through that
in a billion years uh if we are if we
will survive all the other catastrophes
but my point is that's something to keep
in mind when we look for set signal
radio signals you know they cannot come
from a star that evolved into the red
giant phase you know like most of the
sunlight Stars went through that and
therefore just forget about it well I
guess you know the my my point in
bringing this up is that you know you I
either have two different uh conjectures
one is that the day after we discover
unequivocal evidence for the existence
of life outside of the Earth
that will transform everything and I I
sometimes feel like that stands in
direct
contradistinction to the fact pattern
that we've already seen and that's the
following in 1996 late 1996 early 1997
President Bill Clinton stood on the
White House lawn and announced the
discovery of meteorites not unlike this
uh and Antarctica where I've been twice
and I've spent about a month of my life
there and uh it's a Barren place it's a
frozen dead continent uh just like the
ice Planet Hoth um I I I love the people
there but I wouldn't want to live there
right uh now that was never falsified in
fact there were in order to get a NASA
press conference on the White House lawn
it had to be peer-reviewed right AI uh
and and that peer review process took
place and it's never been anti- peer
reviewed it's never been retracted
formally and my question to you guys is
why wait what was the what was the
results ites from the Allen land Hill
meteorite fall was actually discovered
and it was believed to either contain
microbial life okay this one yeah right
and that was and you can see it in the
movie contact there's a scene where
President Clinton is talking and jod
Foster's on and uh and that's really
real it's not CGI he actually did that
and they used the actual NASA press
conference so my point is that we
already in the general public has
already been through this they don't
know it's been retracted I mean I meet
people all the time that don't know my
bicep two paper was you know the
conclusions were retracted and AI knows
that story very well because he was
there uh but I want to ask you guys the
question Gary if the general public you
know really hasn't gotten up in arms
about this discovery which in their
minds is still valid it's still a actual
scientific discovery what makes us think
that if you come up with proof or AI
comes up with some discovery that
anything will be different 20 years from
now well you know I I said this before I
think if it doesn't affect kitchen table
issues um or doesn't challenge
somebody's religion uh or their status
in the in the world they probably will
just ignore it um until it I I think EES
out in and leaks out into into the
general scientific framework so that it
becomes as of many things uh it now is
an accepted fact and two years ago it it
it wasn't so I I mean I'm I'm perfectly
fine with the public
not agreeing with the conclusions or any
conclusions at any point in time I'm
only I'm only interested in convincing a
sufficient cadr of
scientists uh that something is worth
studying uh so that you know continued
research can be done on it I mean you
know I was I often say I was I was
raised Catholic but brought up Jewish uh
by uh two fantastic scientist mentors
when I was a gr gr student here at
Stanford Leonard and and Leonard
herzenberg and Lee herzenberg the the
the wife was always with the when I
asked a certain question says Gary
you're asking a question that is yes or
no and you can that's sort of a Las
Vegas question you can be spending so
much of your time uh on a no and you've
wasted you know as many months or years
of your life as possible sometimes it's
easy enough to just switch the mode of
the question around so that it's a Zen
outcome uh so that no matter what the
answer is it's interesting and so I
think that this is one of those kinds of
questions this whole subject matter it
doesn't matter what the answer is I mean
if it's if it's no it's maybe
disappointing but that's still
interesting because that means life on
on Earth is unique but if it's yes uh if
it's yes that there is life even in our
own solar system doesn't proved There
Are UFOs or
uaps but it is at least a step in the
direction of saying well it could have
been I'm convinced that no matter what
we find on mars or under the oceans of
Titan or what have you are is going to
be you know is going to be related to us
whether it started there and came here
or vice versa I don't really necessarily
care but there are actually genetic ways
to to get at that probably by the way
Brian I should emphasize to me science
is about learning I mean it's a learning
experience about reality okay so uh
nature is educating us and we better pay
attention it's a dialogue with nature
it's not a monologue okay and very often
we get into a monologue which is a very
bad um attitude when you date with a
partner right you need to listen to the
other side and that's why experiments
are so important okay now the point why
is it beneficial to us to listen and
figure out what reality is is because we
it allows us to adapt to it if we have
the wrong ideas if we live in the
metaverse and put goggles on our head
and believe that we look like Brad Pit
all day long and that we are very
attractive next to celebrities you know
we may feel good about oursel but it
will not be the reality that we all
share and the same if you take
recreational drugs you may feel high and
very good and but it's not the reality
that now the scientific inquiry allows
us to figure out what reality is and
sometimes it contradicts our you know
prior beliefs like quantum mechanics you
know was in conflict with the
traditional thinking and Einstein had a
problem with that but he was wrong okay
so the point of the matter is that by
understanding why you are wrong you can
then realize how to cope with the new
sense of reality so for example if you
know that the Earth moves around the sun
when you design a space mission you take
that into account if you believe very
decisively that the sun moves around the
earth you will never get to your
destination by launching a rocket okay
because you have the wrong idea so
reality is whatever it is and we better
adapt to it and the only way to do that
is by you know collecting data not human
beings are not scientific sensors
they're not scientific tools we learn
that over history that's why we we are
using instruments and that's what
Science is based on so collecting
quantitative data and understanding your
instruments and then learning something
new about reality will benefit us no
matter what we find absolutely and I
wonder Gary what do you tribute and and
I think you know just with with all lack
of false sincerity to mix a lot of
things uh I think you in particular have
been in part uh crucial in the
destigmatization of this phenomena and
to the fact now that it's being studied
by none other than NASA what do you
attribute the recent upsurge that kind
of you know the three of us are old
enough maybe to remember Nancy carrian
uh why me you know why now why is this
becoming in the in the Forefront of our
Collective you know frontal lobe why is
it not the Avi lobe uh why is it uh why
is it now coming to the Forefront such
that what was previously derided and you
have suffered a lot of slings and arrows
personing G why is it now coming you
sort of kosher to to investigate this so
much so that NASA itself is
investigating it what do you attribute
that to well I I I think it's a
conversation across the multiple fields
of let's say human
professional uh uh Arenas I mean one
it's the Sciences um you know it was for
me actually very exciting when um Avi
got on board because I felt like okay
well here's another person uh another
serious scientist uh that I can point to
and say say yeah I'm not the only I'm
not the only one um but I second you
know I think it was the really the
efforts of people in the intelligence
Services I mean we all know of Lou
alzando and Chris melon and then the
pilots who came forward and not because
I think that they're they were
addressing some sort of conspiracy they
were actually being
scientists they were saying look there's
there's data off the curve here that
needs to be understood we don't know
what it is uh and I think them going
public and going I mean everything even
though the the the New York Times
article changed things in back in 2017 I
think those Pilots being on 60 Minutes
it was that kind of personal uh frankly
anecdote uh that was you know given and
conveyed by um by credible individuals
uh that changed things because you you
heard people speaking in their own terms
I mean I can speak to another scientist
in my own terms with in my own language
anguage of Science and they will believe
me because of that so there was
something essentially very human about
what these individuals did were they
they took more bricks and arrows than
than I ever did um and and so I think
that it was it's that kind of back and
forth there's a there's a Ricochet
effect occurring um where I I don't
think we can expect that Ricochet to be
sufficient to propel it I think we need
to Contin to work on it and frankly we
need to I need to be able to provide the
kind of proof that I think another
scientist would agree with me is is
irrefutable and I've had I think that's
kind of what it's about last year I had
on um Jim semivan you know former CIA um
operative executive maybe uh along with
Tom dong with my good friend Kurt jongle
who may be listening his YouTube channel
theories of everything everyone should
subscribe to that uh conversation and
actually thank you Kurt for putting me
in touch with Gary I have to give
hakarat right AI uh when I talk about uh
these these subjects with Tom dong he
mentioned a problem that he has but he's
not a scientist so he could get away
with it and that was that he claimed to
have alien technology an artifact from a
a downed Craft um and he claims that
it's 100% genuine however the means by
which he acquired it cannot be either
divulged or reproduced in other words
there's a chain of custody problem that
Avi and I don't suffer from right if Ai
and I look at a uh at a muon uh their
muons are like Commodities they're
fungible one mu you've seen one muon
you've seen them all um they're they're
interchangeable uh but but alien craft
aren't and so therefore it's very
important the provenance so to speak and
I and I guess I'm wondering you know
from your excursions what do you make of
of the claims of say Tom dong or or
jacqu Val who I know you you've worked
with well if he's if he's talking about
the uh the the so-called um magnesium
bismuth metam material um you know I I
have pieces of that uh and I don't think
that there is sufficient evidence at
this point to claim that is clearly uh
you know from an extraterrestrial
vehicle um that said I don't think that
sufficient analysis has been done on it
it does have slightly altered magnesium
ratios i' I've looked at that myself but
they're not so far off that they that
they can't be um construed as some other
sort of reason for in in the in the
making of it so unless he's talking
about something else I I don't I don't
know and nor have I seen it uh the the
evidence and so it's I I I put it into
the into the anecdote category and I
like Tom I mean I'm I'm a you know he's
a friend uh but I I haven't seen
anything else now I have been given uh
pieces of material that do have chains
of evidence this is the so-called uat
tuba event where we did do a very
detailed uh analysis using secondary ion
Mass Spec of the isotope ratios of two
pieces one was and we did it in the same
instrument at the same time under the
same vacuum conditions uh one piece was
perfectly conventional uh magnesium
ratios the other were way off I mean so
far off as to be the only thing that I
could imagine is it was manufactured now
that doesn't prove it's a UAP that
doesn't prove it was alien it just says
to me somebody back in the 70s spent a
lot of money to change the isotope
ratios and then blew it up over a beach
in Brazil and so the only question that
raises to me is who would do that and
why would they do it right I mean
because we don't use Isotopes or
anything other than either medical
reasons or blowing stuff up so so if I
may add there Brian so um given the
landscape that I described before of
scientists being skeptical and then
Believers being very um proactive in um
so forth uh given that you would ask
yourself okay who would be the first to
notice something unusual it's obviously
the
government who has the day job of
worrying about National Security because
they have to monitor the sky at all
times yeah and you know protect military
personnel so they keep patrolling or
looking from above from
satellites on Earth and if there is
anything unusual they would be the first
to notice it because the astronomers
build telescopes that focus on a small
region of the sky look at very distant
sources and if something flies above
their telescope they dismiss it and even
if they see an object from intera space
that looks unusual they would say oh
it's a rock of a type that we've never
seen before so you can C the by the way
an anecdote a colleague of mine wrote a
review paper in annual reviews of
astronomy and astrophysics about UAA the
first reported in object and he said I
just finished writing it uh a review
about the comet om mua mua and I said
what do you mean the comet UA we all
know that there was no cometary tale
detected and in fact the spe Space
Telescope looked very deeply couldn't
see any traces of carbon based molecules
so he said well I have a
that in fact the this object had a
commentary tale when we didn't look at
it and didn't have a commentary tail
when we looked at it so I said that's
just like going to the zoo and looking
at an elephant and saying the elephant
is a zebra it's just that the stripes
show up when you don't look at at at the
elephant and just think about it
mainstream astronomer writing the
authoritative review on an object that
looked unusual and calls it something
that is inappropriate like a comet why
would he do that first he has the
backing of people that say oh it's
natural forget about it second he wants
to have the Cozy warm feeling of
something familiar okay so when you call
it a comet you feel okay we can move on
now my point is this is not supposed to
be the way science is done we are all
supposed to be kids wondering about the
world without pretensions without
pretending that we are experts of we
know everything and without bullying any
opinion that might be different than
ours that is the way science should be
done and here I see a problem because
when young scholars see this Behavior
they hesitate to innovate and then
science is not progressing at the same
rate as it should it should be blue sky
research we should encourage young
people to be creative to deviate from
dogmas and you know it's just very
depressing to me to see this be and he's
Young by the way so he wants to show as
if he size up because he's looking for a
job but this should not be the climate
that we live I agree I've often said you
know there was a guy in the in the 1850s
who had these incredible ideas that
there was an ether and that the uh space
of the vacuum was actually not a vacuum
there were little gears and whirlpools
and vortices and thank God for James
Clerk Maxwell that Twitter didn't exist
back then because he would have been
ridiculed and humiliated and we would
have thrown the electromagnetic laws
that are associated with his name 160
years later out with the bath water but
I think you're wrong Obby because I
think scientists are like children I
mean we don't play well with others
we're very jealous we like attention and
we and we don't like to share our toys
right so I want to ask Gary when our
when we see things like this and aie
please you too and I just want to remind
every we're talking about AI lobe Gary
Nolan uh some of the most eminent uh
scientists who happen to have turned at
Great personal risk and I want say this
with respect um I don't have the courage
that you guys do I I kind of do this
because I believe that we as scientists
have a moral obligation to share the
data to share the uh discoveries in a
way that our taxpaying public who pay
our freaking salary I don't care you
guys are at private institutions I'm not
a public institution but you guys are
supported by the public at a a very deep
level as well I just want to put that
out there I feel it's my moral
obligation to share but I don't have the
courage to go out on a limb to go on
Tucker Carlson like like Gary to go on
the various Outlets that that you've
gone on as well Obi because I I I am
worried I'm worried about the the
obviously there's there's career risk
Etc but there's also kind of a
intellectual capture that occurs when
when you believe something to be true
that no one else maybe agrees with you
or very few of your colleagues agree
with you it's a very lonely place and
and I'm just saying in all honesty not
many scientists have that courage not
many uh people have that c courage is
the rarest of all human emotions in my
opinion so I just want to express that
but I do want to say along the lines of
data I've heard people say and when Avi
was on with Eric Weinstein we heard
things like the data is ours it belongs
to the public I don't know if I
necessarily disagree that the data
belongs to the public but don't we have
an obligation as scientist Gary to
interpret the data are very complex
someone who's watching this channel may
be a lay person very bright brilliant I
mean the smartest audience in the
universe uh watches this channel but do
they have the tools to assess at the
level that you do because of your
because of the privilege that you have
to be a scientist can an average lay
person really understand what it is that
maybe you might be claiming or or is it
your job to explain it in a way that
they could does it belong basically I
mean again this is kind of a literally a
riff on what um on what AI just said I
don't think of frankly what we're doing
as courageous I'm just doing what I
thought science was teaching me to do
right and that's really what Avi was
saying is that you know that that that
if if if science is about following
rules that somebody else wrote on stone
tablets then science is done right and
so uh I've spent my whole career doing
things that people told me shouldn't or
couldn't be done like when I was doing
starting companies back in the early 90s
or mid 90s I was told you're going to
you know destroy your career you
shouldn't do it now everybody does it
right and people people who used to come
to me and tell me I'm ruining my career
come ask me how to start a company uh so
that's that's fine so I don't consider
it I don't consider it courageous I'm
just doing what I think we're supposed
to be doing um you know that's the
that's the first part of it and sorry
what was the second part of your
question that you know when we see data
for example I'll hear it that you know
the Deep Field is data right it belongs
to the public NASA made the Hubble Deep
Field uh James web telescope but um it's
a pretty picture at one level right AI
it it doesn't really have spectroscopic
image so what level do you have to have
as a responsibility Obi to distill it in
a way that the general taxpaying
audience who pays our salaries at some
level should understand yeah so that's
the rationale for the gal project where
we say we don't need to wait for the
government to declassify data we'll just
collect data that we will open to the
public so that everyone can see it uh
and we are funded by donations and
therefore we owe nothing I mean there is
no um level of of of of secrecy the
other thing I wanted to mention very
often uh funding is not done from the
private sector but from committees that
allocate federal funds to researchers
and these committees argue we shouldn't
take risks because otherwise we will
waste taxpayers money well guess what if
you were to ask the taxpayers uh what do
they care about more the nature of Dark
mattera Being let's say the lightest
super symmetric particle or um whether
we are alone or in our class of
intelligence civilizations in the Milky
Way galaxy they would say the latter and
if you don't want to waste taxpayers
money you should put it all in the
direction that taxpayers want it to be
spent and that poll was never made so
instead what you have is the mainstream
deciding on it on its own what's what
they believe is risky and as a result
they suppress innovation in other
directions and I say you know this
subject is different it's not just that
I'm deviating from the path in trying to
pursue it it's the path that the public
cares about the most and that will have
a huge impact on the future of humanity
so by calling it thinking outside the
box we are missing the point the box is
in the wrong place I'm thinking straight
based on common sense and one day my
hope is the Box will be placed when I'm
exactly at the center of that box okay
but it takes time and that happened to
me multiple times in my career where I
just did what common sense makes because
after all I'm a farm boy you know I was
born on a farm I don't feel that I'm
that I belong to any Elite uh even
though I was chair of the astronomy
department at Harvard for nine years you
know I feel like the common person I
think straight I think with my common
sense I try to reflect what the public
cares about and my point is that uh you
know that's the way that science should
be done that we should be just you know
um pursuing what people care about in
instead what you find in Academia is a
lot of acrobatics of people trying to
show off that they are smart and
sometimes they go in dark alleys that
nobody cares about like worrying about
how many angels can dance on the head of
a pin you know the equivalent of that
would be to say let's work for 50 years
about the notion of exod Dimensions
without evidence without evidence for
super symmetry you invested the a lot of
billions of dollars in the large hydron
collider we didn't find it okay my point
is it's not a bad thing to do that
though those things but at the same time
you shouldn't ridicule study of
something that the public cares about
that will have huge impact and that so
far was not funded federally at all and
why would we even doubt that thing you
know why would we if we are doing we are
sending inell props why wouldn't we
search for others that were sent in our
Direction in my view it's a completely
natural thing to do and the the
community is like 180 degrees away from
where it should be so it's the box that
is in the wrong place
you know I'm not thinking outside the bo
I'm thinking what I you know is
following common sense the box is out of
the common sense that's what I would
arue I want to ask you you know OB I
want to throw I want to throw a bit of a
stink bomb though at Nasa if I may yeah
go for it um this
UAP uh committee that they're doing the
task force y several of those so-called
scientists and I'm going to call you a
so-called scientist until you prove
otherwise whoever I'm uh deriding here
have come out before they've even said
anything and done many of the things
before they've even done the analysis
and have done many of the things that AI
has been uh discussing they've they've
pre-boxed their conclusions and
protected themselves against others
being uh who might uh uh say something
negative about them because of being
even on the committee how so how so Gary
well I you know I think I can't remember
the name of the woman but she basically
came out and said something along the
lines of we don't think that any of this
stuff is uaps and
uhan Nadia Drake probably the daughter
of Frank Drake She TW yeah I mean she
made a statement and then there was
another person a be or maybe it's a he
just came out this morning he was just
recently uh put on uh the committee he
said something similar where it's like
that what a sad sad scientist you are
that you feel that you have to say
something like that before you even look
at the data um I'm I'm just I'm just
disappointed I I would take people like
that off the committee and I'll do
something say something else I think is
a
little why is it only astronauts and
astrophysicists who are on this
committee why where are the other kinds
of scientists there's many other kinds
of scientists Sor there actually is
there's Paula Boni she's a biological
oceanographer there's the industry
people from uh from the biological
oceanographer oh there's pic Institute
of of policy studies I I agree David
grinspoon is a planetary scientist
actually
ition of a type of scientist that I
think um has a predilection to not uh
think outside of the box or in the right
box um because they're more afraid of
what they're colleagues might think than
others I I I question the constituency
of the individuals who are on that
committee but but but accepting that
let's ask the meta question Gary is this
a good thing is it is it in principle I
mean we shouldn't prejudge their
conclusions just as as as you are I'm
happy i' be delighted if they prove me
wrong okay way by the way I met with the
committee and had a very good
conversation with them the one thing
that surprises me is not what Gary just
mentioned what surprises me is that a
year ago there was a committee appointed
by the seti community and decided not to
have discussions on UAP unidentified
aial phenomena in any of the conferences
related to seti now you ask yourself
setti is supposed to be the closest Ally
to the study of objects that are unusual
okay uh why would they reject any
discussion and dismiss it up front not
allowing any discussion in their in
their
conferences and the only way I can
understand that is they want to distance
themselves from from those studies
because they want to show the rest of
the community that in fact they are in
the middle they are actually mediators
and they are more sane than another
group in their mind and as a result they
deserve funding and I find that that
apologetic tone to be completely
inappropriate we should search for radio
signals fine we didn't find any in 70
years just like waiting for a phone call
but we should also search our mailbox
for any packages that arrived and that's
a completely different method and I
don't see a contradiction and I don't
see why one is supposed to be considered
as less uh valuable or as less worth
pursuing especially when the government
comes out and see and sees things they
don't understand so let's just figure it
out and why should the SEI community be
the one to resist studies of UAP so I
find that really strange I must tell you
because it shows how the dynamic of
Academia is controlled by societal
forces not by logical thinking do you
think that they are under constraints
let's say they discover something you
know potentially transformative you know
or definitive proof that aliens don't
exist whatever that means okay no are
they under constraints because they they
are not gonna I've I've spoken with
David spurgle who happens to be a
personal friend of mine um and he's not
going to come on the I mean he said he'd
come on the podcast but he has this
thing called the US Congress to testify
in front of first okay so that'll come
down the line shelle writes uh my
upstairs neighbor uh UC San Diego so
they they are sworn you know to do a
good job and come out with these results
now on one hand we we have talked about
you know the the the fallibility or the
or the implicit bias that we have as
human beings to confirm or refute
hypotheses that agree or disagree with
our preconceived notions now I've heard
a lot of say and there is a substantial
amount of Aviation and space you know uh
related people that are on this uh
including people from the FAA um I have
heard a lot of things from Pilots uh
over the past couple of years and I
happen to be a pilot with uh with
instrument ratings and and all sorts of
of goodies that fly little tiny planes
around uh Southern California not far
from by the way where some of these Tic
Tacs and stuff were observed but uh I
want to get your impression first of all
AI uh uh and then Gary uh for the claims
of of Commander David fraver you know
you can't comment on their braver I mean
they're far braver and they've done
things that I'll never do and I never
criticize them uh you know personally
but we're you know we're very skeptical
of eyewitness evidence in a courtroom
why are we so you know willing to
believe in the Pro UFO UAP as alien
craft why is it so readily accepted that
the testimony of an eyewitness who is
mostly trained to look at his
instruments and flying his instruments
or her instruments um why do we take
that with outsize credulity AI first and
then Gary I'd like to get your
impression of I don't think we it should
be regarded as scientific evidence uh
now let me first comment on why I think
you see the behavior of members of the
committee or others in seti and so forth
uh there was a congressman uh who
expressed anti-gay statements publicly
when he was in Congress okay and once he
retired a couple of years ago he
confessed that he is gay okay and what
does it show you about human psychology
that very often people are really
intrigued by something and they pretend
to be something else okay so because of
what they see around them and I think a
lot of that is happening in the context
of UAP those that object to it the most
are the ones that are actually very
intrigued by them and by the way in
religion very often if you want to
convert someone to a religion those that
you know you target those that object
the most because they care about it and
then you realize you can convince them
so anyway just putting that aside with
respect to fravor and all these
testimonies you know they're intriguing
they're fascinating and of course we
want to believe that there is something
else out there because it's fascinating
it's intriguing the it will change
everything but from a scientific point
of view I'll tell you two I I'll give
you two scenarios that could explain
what the nits report was about one is
there was a swarm of objects okay so
they saw an object at one point and then
short time later it was behind them now
they say it moved so fast you know that
nothing can do that but in fact it was
two different objects that came in and
out of view and it was not the same
object so unless you have scientific
evidence you're dealing with you know
you can re the Ser read the serial
number of the object and tell that it's
the same object it may not be the same
object it could also not be a physical
object like if you have a laser pointed
at a you know and creating a blob of hot
gas that appears in your infrared uh
images and appears in your radio images
it may not be a real object so we don't
know maybe there was some new equipment
the government was testing and not
telling those those who saw it uh the
point is that this is intriguing enough
for me or the Galileo project to build a
suite of instruments that we will employ
and bring to those locations and you
know monitor the sky take a video of the
sky in the infrared the optical the
radio and try to figure it out if if it
comes back again and we will of course
let everyone know and it will not be I
Witnesses so the point of the matter is
this is good enough to trigger
scientific inquiry it's not good enough
as scientific evidence I agree I mean I
call it like I said before it's
preliminary data I could be working at
my bench or when I used to work at the
bench uh and I can see something in the
data uh that to me is pretty clear
evidence but I know that there is a
standard of proof that's required to
hand to others and so you know if we
could get all of the necessary data from
the fraver and the other individuals
maybe that could be you know constituted
as as actual proof um but you know I so
I think in a in a nod to the to the true
Skeptics I don't mean the the pseudos
Skeptics and the pathological Skeptics
it's like yeah we haven't done our job
yet uh or the job isn't we we don't have
the necessary access to do the job so I
think what the Galileo project is doing
and uh is exactly what needs to be done
is just you know let's take it into our
own hands and do it and if the
government wants to participate and have
us help that's a that's a great thing I
mean one other thing that I think is
kind of exciting though about this
notion of um let's say preliminary
evidence or whatever if if some
civilization has made it past the
inflection point of self- imulation that
we are you know seem to be on the prace
of ourselves I see that as a positive
thing um I I look at you know these
supposed events that people see in these
objects even if they're not real as as
a as a horizon to which we can Aspire
right if something can do this or if we
if we force our minds to think well can
we do something like that that to me is
a is a fantastic uh way to excite the
younger generation to come up with new
ideas and new technologies even if
everything that uh is going on around
uaps ends up being to be a complete uh
an utter illusion
right well we're going to take questions
from the audience so uh I've seen couple
thousand comments go by uh but I'm going
to start start the process now of
actually looking through them uh by
taking my host prerogative and just a
reminder we're talking with Professor
Avi lobe of uh a small institution in
Cambridge I love it when I meet somebody
from from Harvard Avi and they say I go
to school near
Boston in Cambridge Massachusetts oh
really you go to the Cambridge Institute
of H virology um so I I will Define the
the institution as having smarter
undergrads than many faculty I know
everywhere wow well that is uh in
contradistinction to William F Buckley
Jr who said I'd rather have my me my
government be comprised of the first 50
names in the Boston phone book than the
faculty of Harvard University but I did
I did once meet somebody who said I go
to the best university in the world uh
and I said oh yeah which one she said
I'll give you a clue it starts with an h
and ends with a D
and I said Harvard she said Howard are
you crazy um so that's shout out to uh
some of my young colleagues um Gary
Nolan joining us from Stanford
University um AI has some book news that
I want to share and first of all I put
links to both the uh gentleman's web uh
Pages down in the in the description I
put a link to the paper that Gary
referred to about uh the wow signal and
DNA uh but uh but in particular ai's got
a series of articles in addition to his
uh Smash Hit book called
extraterrestrial which he for which he
was on the show a year ago or two years
ago now I can't believe it Obby it's
going to be two years in January and
he's promised he'll come back for his
new book uh say a little bit about your
new book Obby yeah it's called
Interstellar and it will be about the
implications to humanity of everything
we discussed so stay tuned for that I
should say that um you know over the
past since my previous book appeared I I
was on about 1,800 podcasts and
interviews for TV and newspapers and so
forth but the biggest satisfaction came
about a week ago I attended a summit in
Palm Desert and um a woman came to me uh
originally from Iran and she said can I
have a selfie with you and I said sure
she knew about me and she took a selfie
and then she said the the following
morning she said I posted it on
Instagram and there are hundreds of
Iranian women scientists that wrote back
to me and said that they are following
your work and I thought to myself wow
that's quite remarkable because I'm
originally from Israel and I'd never
imagined there would be hundreds of
Iranian women following my work and I
basically recorded a
video snippet with her in which I
supported the women of Iran in their
fight right now in the protest so what I
would like to say is this subject
resonates with a lot of people around
the world a lot of people are excited
about it we are going to do the
expedition to Papua nugini there is a
lot going on
uh every day I get surprising things
happening uh and within a year or two I
bet you that we will have a convers the
landscape will change okay it's not up
to Federal institutions to authorize
progress It's not up to the dogma of
Academia to to tell us what reality is
like we will just figure it out like
kids and then you know I don't really by
the way I keep thinking about gal that
knew the truth about the Earth and the
Sun and was put in house arrest like who
cares whether the public knows about it
whether people don't like it you know
that's completely irrelevant if you know
what reality is like one way or the
other it will the news will break out
okay because that's the reality you can
hide the virus you can avoid people
knowing about it but the virus if it's
there people will get sick you know so
that the reality is whatever it is
irrespec of what humans try to do to
hide it and I like to look at the
pimples of reality I don't want any
makeup you see the people around me try
to put makeup on reality so it looks
better so that we are the only
intelligent you know uh civilization out
there we feel better about oursel this
way I want to to realize if there is a
smarter kid we we want to learn from the
smartest kid in our class that's what we
should aim at because it will give us
inspiration so we want to find who is
smarter you know out there one reason I
search for intelligence in space is
because I don't often can find it when I
open the
newspaper right and G uh a I can't
resist uh you quoting your your top uh
your top aphorism from last appearance
when you were on with Eric Weinstein
I'll put a link to it what did you say
about the sky and being classified AI
well the sky is not classified and um
that's why we should look at it you know
and I think we are we we we should think
of ourself as students of nature let let
nature educate us rather than having a a
monologue in which we say what nature is
supposed to be and part of nature you
know I grew up on a farm and to me
nature is the entire universe okay and
there is M so we are focused most of the
time on the two-dimensional surface of
this rock that we were born on the the
Earth but it's it's it's just a tiny
Rock in in a huge space and and just you
know let's be more modest and and and
look up that's all I'm asking let's look
up let's check our mailbox like why are
we so close-minded you know like uh that
that is really and fery asked 70 years
ago where is everybody that's so
self-centered like to stay at home and
say I don't see my neighbors you know
like what is going on here well you
didn't look through the windows you
didn't use a telescope back in 1950 uh
so how can you claim where is everybody
like that well hopefully we'll we'll get
a lot of good packages in the mail this
Black Friday with books by a uh in them
uh so first question from the audience
uh for Gary uh comes from uh uh one of
my listeners uh who's asking are you
related to Christopher a uh and then an
all seriousness uh red panda koala asks
any updates on the Havana syndrome uh
and have you noticed any patterns and
experiences held by people that you've
encountered so Havana syndrome up
upgraded I mean well the I mean I I mean
the Havana syndrome
relationship work for me basically was
um you know when we had a 100
individuals that were you know the the
some of the data Medical Data was taken
to me you know we had back around 2014
2015 already figured out that there were
um well we had called it at the time
interference syndrome we didn't know
that it was basically some sort of was
related to the um the uh the issues
going on at the um at the US Embassy in
Havana um those cases that I was
involved with with Havana have been
handed over to the US government they're
not my I would say that's a good thing
they're not my problem anymore you know
science is about classification and once
we could classify them as some kind of
frankly uh attack on our diplomatic core
or individuals those individuals were
then taken out of my hands I mean not in
a negative sense just said I could hand
them over because they were class they
were I could classify them as something
other than let's say UAP they weren't
interesting to me anymore because they
were understandable but what was left on
the table and I think is really this is
what the individual is is asking about
um are the individuals who were harmed
in some way or had damage uh who claimed
some kind of UAP interaction again it's
for for me the the story of the UAP
intervention is less interesting to me
than is the damage that happened to them
and how they came about to be damaged
and what was the let's say the
technology that uh caused the damage and
so I I try I've said this before I try
to stay away from the anecdotal aspect
of the story because I can't verify that
but I can look at the same x-ray or the
same medical analysis of an individual
and I can reproduce that analysis and so
that's where I'm I'm focused
uh and I'm sorry if that's not the kind
of answer that uh Mr koala wants but
that's really as far as I'm willing to
go I the other thing I've said is I will
not do science by press release yes I
will wait until the science is vetted by
other individuals I mean I got in big
trouble doing science by press release
with that so-called ocama thing and that
you know I the gentleman Steven Greer
who I had speculated along the way that
I thought that some of the DNA results
looked odd and and maybe it was an alien
or something but they what I found is
that if you speculate to the public who
don't know what the limits of
speculation mean they sometimes take
what you're saying as a conclusion and
when I basically published the paper
showing that this uh unfortunate um
mummy was in fact a young girl likely
born prematurely and had multiple
mutations
in uh genes that were um basically in
bone development genes and I had
literally the world's expert on bone
development genes Ralph lochman from
here at Stanford three other Stanford
professors who were specialists in South
American genetics and all the rest
validate verify the results 13 or 14
postto graduate students Ro science Ro
Diagnostics on the paper etc etc and I
published it it didn't matter they could
all they could basically say was I was I
somehow had convinced a Cadre of 15 or
so people to to fabricate the data
because I got a grant from the dod for
doing ovarian cancer and that was my
payoff I mean I mean that is literally
it's it's that's what I had to go
through and I realized okay you really
do the ethics of how science is done
really do work work you have to stick to
the rules and the rules
are be very careful what you speculate
uh because the people who don't
understand the rules will run with it I
mean we see this in the newspapers and
social media every day so that's why I
won't go any further so I'm sorry red
koala
Panda AI for you this comes from uh
Professor Brian keing if you had
unlimited budget let's just say
unlimited budget what would you be doing
what what could you be doing and Gary
I'm gonna ask you the same question what
would you do with effectively unlimited
budget I'm I'm tweaking this I tweeted
to Elon Musk yesterday about this very
question go ahead Abby yeah I should
note that this is not a hypothetical
question no I know I know it is okay so
uh because I'm I'm you know I I I get to
meet a number of people that are quite
excited uh and many of them come to the
porch of my home to discuss it with me
so you know as I said the two-thirds of
Americans really care about and believe
in extraterrestrial life and you might
assume that many of the
multi-billionaires that became wealthy
recently are drawn out of that
population so many of them care about it
what would I do so um I would follow um
studies along three tracks what which is
pretty much what the gal project is
doing just much more uh forcefully so
one track is um right now I have money
to perhaps um uh duplicate system of uh
instruments that we have maybe a few
times and put it in three locations okay
uh but if I get tens of millions or more
than that I will have I could have
hundreds of those systems and that is
really the minimum needed to U study the
problem thoroughly and get enough
statistics on all the unidentified aial
phenomena that appeared in report so
what I need is a factor of 10 in funding
or more than that and the more the
better in the sense that we know how to
make those instruments in fact this week
is very um sort of historic for the
Galileo project because For the First
time we're getting data from all the
instruments and bringing them to the
computer systems uh that we have and
starting to analyze with artificial
intelligence algorithm so we are as in
the coming weeks we will basically make
sure that everything works and then
within a month or so we can start
planning where to put additional uh
copies of that Suite of instruments and
what I'm limited by is the funding so if
I get enough funding let's say tens of
millions to 100 million that would allow
me to get to the bottom of this question
what are unidentified aerial phenomena I
can promise that and we we can
demonstrate that we know what we are
doing with a current system we just need
more copies of it so that's one track
the second one is going after the
fragments of interstellar meteor so we
are going to papuan nugini to uh scoop
the ocean Flor that's one Interstellar
meteor from 2014 the first Interstellar
object in the solar system tougher than
iron tougher than all the other space
rocks known and therefore it's possibly
of H some artificial alloy composition
so we want to find out by collecting the
fragments and we are fully funded for
that that's a one and a half million but
there is another interal meteor that we
identified and we would like to go after
that as well so that's at the level of a
few million dollars we can go after
Interstellar meteors okay so we have the
Tens of millions or 100 million for the
UAP and uh at the level of Millions for
the Expeditions then the big ticket item
is really space missions so objects that
do not collide with Earth like UA mua
was we could come close to them and take
a close-up photograph and such a mission
is actually a billion dollars in cost so
we are thinking about proposing uh to
space agencies like NASA or others uh
but at first we are
designing the mission the parameters of
such a mission and we will have a dating
app the Vera ruin observatory in Chile
that will start operations next year and
it serves as a dating app because we
will see more objects like UA mua and we
will swipe to the left for most of them
but some of them would look intriguing
and we would like to uh approach them as
they come towards us and perhaps take a
closeup photograph and that's the most
expensive so if I had unlimited budget I
will have those uh you know space
missions that meet unusual Interstellar
objects just like UA mua and take a
close-up photograph maybe even land on
them so that they can tell whether it's
a hydrogen Iceberg a nitrogen Iceberg a
Dust Bunny in which case you will pass
through it these are the suggestions by
advertising billboard right yeah or they
have some screws and bolts and we can
land and I would love to press a button
if it's well actually uh so Joe is
asking a question Joe Wescott is asking
he'd love to help out he's got a lot of
money because he donated uh 20 bucks to
the Super Chat so I'm I'm expecting he's
also a billionaire so now I've had on
five billionaires on the podcast um how
can an ordinary uh stem professional
participate in the Galileo project okay
so we have two uh on the Galileo website
there are two uh items one is how to
contribute if someone wants to
contribute funds um how to support
support us uh and the second is
volunteering to be part of the research
team and there is a different tab for
that and you just fill the fill a form
and we will look at your um credentials
and make a decision great or you can
contact me you can just email me okay
and uh yeah we'll have links we have
links to your website on the comment
section down below Gary if you had
unlimited funds say Phil Knight decides
to make another $400 million donation to
that fair University to let the Winds of
Freedom blow on This research uh what
would you do with unlimited budget it's
really kind of a a surreptitious
question actually well you know as as
some people know I've been interested in
these claimed materials that have been
either Left Behind or or dropped from
these uh uaps I mean there's there's an
interesting um pattern where an object
is seen and uh it drops something often
a molten metal in fact I published a
peer- reviewed paper on exactly this in
uh on a on a well credential
uh event um you know we didn't find
anything unusual but there in terms of
the constituency because it was a mton
metal but how does a molten metal end up
in the middle of a field uh where
everybody saw a glowing blinking object
you know just a a few hours before um so
you know in in in that vein and say uh
looking at things that for instance Tom
Delan says that he has or that others
might have there is there are a range of
scientific instruments which could be
brought to bear as well as a couple that
need to be built including something
called an atomic Imaging scope uh that
um you know if if you have something how
do you prove that it wasn't made here
well you need to know that it was made
of things for instance that humans don't
normally make that's hard to say because
we can pretty much put any set of
elements in a in a that mix them
together and and they'll be there but
it's how they're put together um and if
it isn't an obvious technology nuts and
bolts as AI just alluded to uh then um
how do you understand or how do you
prove that it it is from
elsewhere um but secondly let's say that
you do have something which is
verifiably not human and it is millions
of years ahead of us in in some manner
or developed by a technology or a
civilization farther ahead the the next
point of of just claiming beyond what it
is that it is from somewhere else is
what does it do and how does it do it
and so you know if we're going to learn
lessons from our betters let's say uh
what better way to do it than to
understand the material that it's made
of and so as it turns out I have seen
data supposedly from inside of the
government uh on some of these supposed
materials uh and I was left wanting for
the kind of analysis that were that was
done it just was insufficient
um and so there needs to be sort of a
standardized pipeline of how the data
should be how materials should be
processed so that you can compare apples
to apples oranges to oranges so at the
end of the day you get a report which
can be read by the scientific Community
to say one way or the other I just want
to I just want to produce the data in a
way that is credible and then let the
conclusions flow from the data but I
have you know the the the amounts of
money to create some of those to put
together a suite of such instruments is
in the tens of millions of dollars to do
this and to do the make the instrument
that I want to make uh you know actually
turns out I have the funding for it now
uh but you're talking uh you're talking
a lot of money uh as well I mean
producing data is one thing analyzing
the data is wholly another right and so
you basically need to basically bring in
the the kinds of experts uh PhD and
otherwise to to do it I I can't do it
anymore I don't have the time yeah and I
mean looking at you know infinite
budgets I mean the government can
actually print their own money so in a
certain sense they have infinite budget
are you impressed with the budget
they've dedicated to date to this UAP
task force AI or
Gary I'm I'm satisfied that they're
putting the money to it and so to the
extent that they actually do something
with it and don't come out with some you
know I I hope that they put a report out
uh for commentary before they finalize
that report uh I think I mean that I
think would lend a lot of credibility to
it um so we'll see I'm I'm withholding
judgment and I would love I would love
to say six months from now when they're
done with it I'm sorry to the committee
for insulting them okay uh next up AI
this is for you uh you can obviously
comment on whether or not you think the
sufficiency of the federal government
NASA budget is adequate do you just
comment on that quickly
AI well we don't know what it will be um
the right now it's a study that was
funded at 100K uh and is supposed to
recommend within a year by June
2023 uh how much money NASA should uh
allocate to the study of UAP so this is
not really a study of the nature of
unidentified object it's more about
whether NASA should invest in such a
research uh and therefore the funds will
be allocated if they are recommended
only probably two years from now if you
think about it realistically and My Hope
Is that the landscape of research on
this subject will change in the meantime
because the gal project for example will
collect data and um so I you know I
believe we should not
wait uh for others to approve the
research if there are sufficiently
wealthy individuals that are excited
about this question we can do it ourself
we don't need to wait for anyone you
know it's just like the play of Samuel
Becket waiting for godau you can wait
for ever either for the government to
declassify data or to fund things that
you want it to fund and then you realize
that you're actually the some of your
colleagues are blocking it because they
want the same funding for something else
um but however if the funding comes from
the private sector and most of my
funding came from the private sector
over the past decade and I established
um a new center at Harvard that
unrelated to the subject on black holes
for example and all of the funding comes
from foundations or private donations
and my point is uh in that case you can
explore new territories and you can
pretty much decide about what seems
exciting what is exciting to the public
and uh I think that's a much better path
for Innovation simply because of the
reasons we discussed before that there
is a lot of inertia for experts to claim
that they already know everything and
they deserve more prices in addition to
the ones they already deserve therefore
new knowledge should not be gaed because
it would threaten their status yeah uh
so comes in another question this is
from a a fellow farmer Obby Simon farmer
who asked the following question um what
criteria do you have established to
determine if uh you spot something uh
whether or not its design is terrestrial
human-made or not oh it's very simple um
basically the two categories of objects
that we are familiar with these are
human-made objects or natural objects we
all know about airplanes drones
satellites weather balloons yes um you
know Rockets um these are human made and
we also know about birds insects you
know and uh meteors that are Rocky and
so the first task is to basically um see
if everything we we find in the sky
belongs to one of these two and if we
see an object behaving in ways that are
not uh explainable as human-made
technology because we don't have that
capacity you know we pretty much know
the limitations of existing I mean
either from Espionage or from what we
develop I mean all you know countries
around the world are not Head and
Shoulder above the us so we pretty much
know our limits and if we see something
behaving technologically far you know
better than what we can produce then we
know that you know it's not us and at
the same time if we verify that it's not
biological it's not natural uh then we
know that it's not from this Earth okay
so that's really uh now we still don't
know what it is so my point is it will
take a long time for through the
learning experience of figuring out what
it's seeking what kind of information is
trying to get how should we respond to
it uh and we don't have a protocol for
that there is no organization that
represents Earth because we never
imagine that we'll have a visitor in our
backyard or that we will find a package
in our mailbox you know if you find a
package in your mailbox that is not sent
by your family members but uh in the
home you know like send to just put
there by your kids or something um if
it's if it came from far away you know
you have to decide what to do with it
because you don't know what what's
inside and one way to figure it out
maybe is to try and and learn about it
what is it trying to do what is uh what
could be the content of this package and
and that will be a learning experience
we can use artificial intelligence for
that because a it might be equipped with
AI itself you know so our AI systems
will have kinship to their AI systems
more than to us and that's the way I see
the future by the way I'm very proud of
our technological kids AI systems uh I
don't necessarily think about sending
humans to space I think about sending
technological gadgets that are equipped
with AI and so I think it will be a
learning curve uh for us to figure out
what it is but at first the first step
is just
to uh find something that is not
familiar okay that's the first a
follow-up question from Anton sh asks uh
are you gonna open source the either AI
or the machine learning research data is
that going to be open source and he says
kaggle is a good platform yeah yeah so
okay so we are currently developing it
and we are also starting to collect data
eventually the data will be public and
the tools that we use will be public so
people can check us and also do their
own work that's the way science is done
and we plan to follow that until you
know we verify that things work to our
satisfaction you know before that it's
premature we don't want to cry wolf you
know for no good reason so we want to
actually uh veryify that what we're
getting is is is reliable we calibrate
our instruments we will test our
algorithms and we have already eight
papers that we submitted to the Journal
of astronomical instrumentation where we
describe the instrumentation that we are
currently already testing uh so we will
be open as open as possible uh that will
be a breath of fresh air into the
subject because people are used to
secrecy or I mean it's clear why the
government has classification because
they collect the data by sensors that
that are classified they don't want
adversaries to be aware of the
capabilities of the US so uh it's not so
much the data it's the sensors and if we
developed our our own sensors that are
open you know off the shelf then we have
nothing to
hide next question comes from my friend
Delon Levy uh who asks um Gary does the
does or did the government or some other
earth based institution have a live
alien and what if anything did they
learn about these internal composition
of such
creatures if such and I'm not dering it
and I've you know I've seen fascinating
you know a fascinating movie moment of
contact from James Fox about uh some of
these kinds of events I don't know I've
not seen anything um and uh so is sadly
it's it it's anecdote um but I think
there's a there's a different kind of
question question that is being asked
here is how do you deal with um the
hundreds or thousands of individuals uh
and often uh children their testimonies
how do you deal with the testimonies of
individuals as as let's say basy and
priors uh you know how do we deal with
that kind of information um and is it
sufficient to get uh others interested
again there's different audiences is
it's not sufficient for a scientist as
proof but maybe it's sufficient for
politicians uh that it's worth um you
know at the very least I mean John Mack
from Harvard actually went through
exactly this is whether whether what
these people are seeing or not is is
interesting or real it does tell you
something interesting about the human
mind yeah I I would like to mention an
anecdote that I was asked by the Boston
magazine um uh when they made a profile
about me um a year ago that um um about
what will happen if a spacecraft landed
uh in our backyard and my wife said if
they land back then she said if they
ever land and want to pick you up just
make sure that you leave the car keys
with me and ask them not to ruin the
loan when they take off now actually I
was asked this question again at a forum
public forum just a month ago and I so
when I came home I asked my wife again I
asked her did you change your opinion
and she said to me that well this time I
will tell you make sure that you turn
off the lights and I will join you
because she's a little bit disappointed
with what's going on around the world
now uh so you know there might be an
opportunity for us to stay together even
if I go on board wonder I wonder what
the frequent F mile situ would you get
you know alien Premier gold or magnesium
you get magnesium status I tell you what
My worry is when I go to Europe I see
the same movie again and again but if
you go to Alpha centuri you'll have to
see it millions of times that that will
be very boring well unless unless it
goes faster than light ofy that's true
that's true uh we could all be using the
alier drive or some derivative yeah Gary
uh mumi which is one of the names I
chose for one of my kids actually uh
sends us a Norwegian donation asking you
Gary do you have an update on the sphere
you got from heart I don't cold heart
well yeah this is another um situation
where you know somebody had some
anomalous I I I won't go into the into
the details of it here but they have an
anomalous material and it's the same
thing I've said to to others
is um yes I have the I have the material
no I have not yet done the analysis
because I'm not going to do the analysis
until I have all of the right
instruments l lined up so that uh when I
do it it's not just it's just not a
one-off data point it's a one-off data
point is useless it's correlated to
nothing yes and so um you know as as I
said it's expensive people don't
understand how expensive it it is yeah
okay so I run it I'll I'll get iron and
maybe some chromium or whatever that
doesn't improve anything to anybody yeah
so you know I just it's just and even if
I did if it if it were something worth
uh you know uh announcing I won't do it
in a press release I'll publish a paper
probably in a really boring place and
let the world deal with it from there
because one data point in isolation is
nothing to me let me ask you this
question that that came up in the
context of a of a friend of mine who was
uh received I won't say too much about
it not to be you know purposely
mysterious but but just because I don't
know if it's anyway he wanted to use
some campus resources um you know uh
x-ray fluorescent spectroscopy etc etc
to look at some um uh some ancient
artifacts found uh in a shipwreck and
and this was uh you know something that
we could look at with tools that we have
here and he was even willing to pay for
it but the question came up you know can
you use you know campus resources or
even government do you think you know
you might face if if you did get you
know as part of your reluctance to to
kind of I mean obviously you want to
avoid being on People magazine although
I was just in People magazine recently
not for world's sexiest man don't get
your hopes up uh but instead guys it was
for a comment I made about the sun uh
but but anyway um Gary do you speaking
about that I don't know if I mention to
you but um one day um someone pointed
out to me a tweet uh of a husband who
said his wife got she said she has a
crash of on an on a scientist named ailo
but who she thinks is sexier than
Anthony fouchi and I mentioned it
immediately to my wife good and her
response was fouchi is a low
bar you guys you should be on the Bor
circuit I know well that's our yeah we
we Obi and Brian we we we do go on tour
uh but Gary would would you face
opposition for using you know do you
have to be totally privately funded no
not at all um first of all I mean I
would't I won't use NIH funds to do
things for you know that are aren't
validated but I have an endow chair yes
uh that you know it it basically
generates a few hundred, doar a year
that I can use for anything I happen to
be on very good terms with the family uh
that originally donated the money that
generates those endowed funds for me
every year they're perfectly fine with
me doing it um and Stanford is perfectly
fine with me doing it because at the
higher levels uh at least he at least
here they're you know they understand
that inquiry like this is is uh laudable
um and if they ever dared to try to stop
me I would find ways to embarrass
them ominous that's uh good to know and
I don't want to get on your bad side
Gary and and if you are related to
Christopher Nolan that that could even
be more impressive okay we're going to
ask uh some existential questions of
Gary I've asked these to AI but but
actually I want to get it's time for an
update AI uh it was two years ago you
were on the first time on this podcast
um so I'll take a couple more questions
from the audience there's still time in
the closing minutes just a reminder
you're talking to uh professors Avi lobe
good good friend of the show four-time
guest five time now on the into the
impossible podcast I have links to his
previous episodes along with all the
content I've had I've had on Skeptics
Gary you should know I've had on Michael
shurmer I've had on Mick West these are
people I don't know if you want to
comment on them but they've uh they they
are decidedly not on the UFO as alien
technology front well you know that
Michael Shermer uh is also a member of
the gal project and I brought people
from both sides because I think evidence
will eventually so it's sort of like a
lithos test if everyone is united in the
interpretation of the data I know that
we're not missing something so I said
the to so Michael said that at some
point um you know if you find evidence
that is conclusive I will be glad to
write an article about it in my magazine
skeptic MH and I told him you know
that's not enough I want you to change
the name of the magazine from skeptic to
believer to believer wow that's now you
can play the pope uh a we can really mix
up some Catholic and Judaism um okay so
uh just a reminder we're talking AI L of
Harvard and Gary Nolan of of Stanford
University and uh and I'm Brian ke your
humble host of the into the impossible
podcast where we've had on uh dozens of
conversations on this Most Fascinating
subject and we have another one coming
up with jacqu Val another uh introduct
to me by none other than Kurt jongle
who's lurking in the chat room and uh is
been so kind to to introduce me to Gary
and uh and I want to thank him for that
so jacqu will come on I'm trying to get
Eric Weinstein on with jacqu so let me
know give a thumbs up if you'd like to
see that pairing uh before the end of
the year okay and maybe we'll have you
and Eric Weinstein that would be fun I
know he's interested to talk to you
Eric's a friend yeah that would be great
uh and he's also you know been ping
around with people like Lou elzando
lately so I want to get an update for
him um okay and and just a quick
reminder if you do want some
Interstellar uh meteorites you can uh uh
sign up for my mailing list Brian
king.com list and you may win some
extraterrestrial maybe Interstellar I
don't know I can't I can't be sure uh
but uh but maybe Interstellar what's
that they're all Interstellar that's
right okay so Gary you have not been on
uh this podcast but I love to ask the
deepest questions of life because a
scientists you know what they say about
scientists how do you know a scientist
is outgoing Gary because he looks at
your shoes when he talks to you um uh
but we have this Trope that we're you
know we're these unhuman inhuman
androyal you know kind of thinking
robots and and sometimes we deserve it
right uh we're we're we're on some kind
of a spectrum I'm so far on the Spectrum
I'm off the Spectrum but but uh but I do
like to humanize my guess and I'm not uh
implying that you're not human in any
way but I asked these questions and you
haven't really seen them I don't think
but uh they really kind of relate to the
most important things of of Life the
kind of meaning questions of life and I
want to start with something that I
asked Avi about when he was back on the
show and it's something in Hebrew called
a Zava it's an ethical will not a
material will and it has to do with what
you want to leave the planet with in
terms of your wisdom your learning your
your knowledge not your material Goods
which you know I don't know where those
will go uh but what wisdom would you
most want to communicate to all of
humanity and your ideological erors once
you spring forth this Mortal coil as the
Barb
said
um well I I mean these are in some ways
trit but give more than you take
um and you know less than you think you
do uh and listen more to others that the
observations will teach you more than
anything you think you understand I mean
I mean that's to me what I was always
brought up as give more than you
take um and uh and frankly if you can
take
nothing beautiful and leave no Trace
right there no backpacking uh Avi did
you want to comment yeah so so I
actually met with a class of undergrads
at Harvard a couple of weeks ago and my
advice to them was um drawn from the
metaphor of walking on the beach you
know you often see some sea shells that
maintain you know unique colors and and
structure and then these are the the
youngest those that were swept ashore
very recently but those that uh over
time were um rubbing against each other
as a result of being dragged by ocean
waves um they eventually lose their
unique colors and become you know break
up into
indistinguishable U grains of sand okay
so my message to the young people is
don't rub against each other on social
media too often because then you will
lose your unique colors and and the I
want people to maintain it and you know
when I was um a young kid I grew up on a
farm and that taught me that independent
thought is most important in life
because very often humans are swayed by
wishful thinking that that's very common
and uh if you want to find your Truth uh
you should not seek it in others you
should look for it yourself and keep
your unique colors don't surrender to
how many likes you have on Twitter and
besides Twitter may go away so well yeah
I mean if uh if Elon keeps up with his
case of innovation uh although I'm
trying to get him you know to spend a
tenth of what he bought Twitter for on
some uh some transformational physics
project so something's happened to your
sound uh oh what about now can you hear
me now yeah there it goes okay good um
so the next question has to do with and
by speaking of Twitter you can follow
Gary at Gary P noan on Twitter and uh
Avi is to uh his time is too precious so
he's not on Twitter but the Galileo
project has a Twitter account it is
Galileo Pro project one on Twitter and
hopefully it will have a blue check mark
if they can come up with the eight bucks
from one of ai's billionaire buddies
okay next question for you guys uh the
namesake of this podcast uh dates to uh
the man whose Center we have at UCSD the
Arthur C Clark Center for human
imagination and I am the associate
director of that fine August institution
and of course we open the audio podcast
which you can subscribe to as well with
sir Arthur's actual reading of the
following statement and any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from Magic and I want to ask you if you
had access Gary to a monolith an object
of great permanence that could last not
just 120 years but billions of years
into the future what would you put on it
or in it to bepe of the magical
technology that human beings have been
able to construct in our short few
hundred thousand years as a species of
homo sapiens what most Majestic magical
thing in your field maybe you created or
somebody else created would you put on a
monolith to give a little Swagger to
humanity oh I was going to say a Rubik's
Cube but um uh let's see well I think
one of the most amazing devices that
we've created well I mean many but I I I
think any the
lens right because it's a you know the
the the Glass Lens it's a you know it's
emblematic of looking deeper right it's
kind of I mean beyond the wheel uh it's
probably one of the first devices we
ever created that allowed us to look
Beyond ourselves and and that to me is
uh you know perhaps the best that's
great it's interesting that Gary is
thinking in my direction because lenses
are often used in astronomy uh but my
preference would be to put artificial
intelligence uh so that um especially a
system that can evolve and the learn
machine learning uh because then it will
be dynamic and whoever finds it will
interact with it and learn much more if
we store enough information in fact I
was advocating in a recent paper putting
a um you know a a reboot system on the
moon that will be if something
catastrophic happens on Earth we want to
keep all the precious information out
there and so I bought a laptop over the
summer and together with it I had a
backup system that a small tiny dis like
system that keeps all the information so
the same thing we can keep on the moon
and basically communicate to it by by a
laser and transmit all the DNA
information about all life forms on
Earth so that it's stored there and all
human Creations all the music all the
books and so forth so that's sort of of
a monolith um because it keeps all the
information but I will add to that an AI
system that is able to use that like you
know what you use when you Google
something you know that's an AI system
and uh so that would be fun to interact
with yeah no I agree I just uh I put a
CD ROM you know when I did this and
unfortunately you know the Microsoft
paperclip could not decipher the CD
anyway I'm just joking guys uh okay last
two questions for you distinguished
gentlemen actually have to do with
another quote from Sir Arthur C Clark
which is the following he said when a
distinguished but elderly scientist I'm
not calling you guys elderly okay come
off when a distinguished but elderly
scientist states that something is
possible he is almost certainly right
but when they State something is
impossible they are very probably wrong
Gary I want to ask you with all humble
respect and admiration what have you
changed your mind about what have you
been wrong about
well I don't know that I'm right or
wrong about it but I'm more of the
opinion that the universe is somehow
designed or made for life um you know
maybe that's just by lack of
appreciation of of uh of the
possibilities but I I I I'm more of the
opinion that the universe is uh is
somehow constructed to enable life now
could just be that's the way it is but
um it's easy enough to also imagine that
some larger entity uh you know in a
universe beyond us uh you know and we're
encapsulated within that you know
created conditions such that we are here
I just find it fascinating that the way
that all of the objects that operate
down at the fundamental units of of
nature uh can come together in a way
that allow for life I mean I'm in I'm in
a greater level of awe about it if
anything and if awe equals a religious
sort of uh consideration then that's
kind of where I am I've let me connect
to that um so when I started
astrophysics that was 35 years ago uh
there was this notion that the early
universe is simple simply because we
don't have data on it that many people
said that oh cosmology is simple you
know just because we haven't gathered
enough data and once we collect the data
we will find that it's as complex as the
universe nowadays full you know the
universe now has you know in addition to
life it has stars it has galaxies very
complex structures now as we got more
data about the early Universe now we
have a lot of data it's still simple now
this explains the error of time okay
because the universe started simple and
you can ask why and you know some people
advocate for infl Cosmic inflation that
created initial conditions that are
quite unique and simple you know the
universe was pretty much uniform except
for small
fluctuations some of us are not sure
that Cosmic inflation took place and
maybe some other process did it the
bottom line is the universe started
simple and became complex and um you
know if you think about um you our life
it also goes that way we start simple
you know as babies and then we get more
complex as adults uh but here is the
catch complexity doesn't continue
forever okay because eventually we die
and we become really simple once again
so if you look at old people in a way
they're as vulnerable as babies and they
eventually become simple because they
end up dead and so um the same will
happen to our universe now it's sort of
at the peak of its complexity maybe it
will continue for a little while but
eventually we will be surrounded by
vacuum because the expansion is
accelerating and the there will be only
our galaxies surrounded by nothing
because the all the other galaxies will
exit from our Horizon and that's a
simpler State okay and eventually all
the stars will die that's a simpler
State than we have now and life will not
exist so my point is we are used to
complexity increasing with the errow of
time there will be a point where
Simplicity will increase with the arrow
of time so it's not always true that
error of time is in the direction of
increasing complexity and that's all
because of gravity you know that drives
everything in ways that we do not expect
from thermodynamics yeah well guys this
has been fascinating and delightful
speaking of inflation I wish you both uh
much inflation of your waistline
although Avi you're wasting away I I
used a picture you know of AI from like
a year or two ago and uh I had to take
it down because you've you've lost
considerable number of kilos which I
will be conserving those kilos because
you and I are in exchange where I gain
the weight you I I've not been so kind
in the P well since the pandemic started
every day now for three years actually
I've been jogging at Sunrise and I must
tell you it makes me younger I feel
really great about it and it increases
the density of thoughts per unit mass in
my body so how about you Gary do you
have a quick one two second uh daily
routine something important to you or
weekly routine that's that's important
to you uh weekly routine um well I work
in my garden I have a greenhouse I
collect carnivorous plants because what
mad scientists you know shouldn't
collect carnivorous plants as well as
being interested in uaps I've been
interested in that sort of stuff saw you
tweet about that
yeah well uh gentlemen it's been a a
distinct honor for me and I know for my
audience um and uh I hope we can H have
many more conversations like this as new
evidence new data arises and as you guys
uh continue also in your story career uh
Obi you've had a paper out recently
about disconfirming inflation I want to
have you back on for that as well as for
your new book Interstellar which I put
up the uh the the monograph the cover of
it on the screen a couple of uh maybe an
hour ago now Gary I want to have you
back on talk about all sorts of exciting
projects you're involved with get your
opinions on hot topics like crisper
genan editing artificial life in the lab
and other things so hopefully you'll do
me another honor come back on someday
yep happy too thanks so much well for
now everybody thank you so for joining
the podcast a reminder we'll have on
jacqu valet hopefully soon maybe with or
without Eric Weinstein and we'll
hopefully have Gary and Avan many many
times uh to come so please do subscribe
and if you do want to win a chunk of
interstellar space Schmutz I'm shaking
it here these are actual meteorites four
billion years old at least found in
Argentina about uh 500 years ago uh you
can enter to win your chance at Brian
keen.com list and I'll send some to you
guys maybe a Carnivor plant and uh and
then for one lucky winner I will send
you some Uranus soap to keep Uranus
clean everybody enjoy Thanksgiving if
you're in America if you're in Canada I
hope you enjoyed it last month like Kurt
my friend my good friend Kurt jongo I
hope you enjoyed your Thanksgiving I
hope you all have a wonderful uh holiday
season coming up and stay tuned to the
end the impossible podcast bye everybody